Louise remember this is the day that you
almost call captain
[Music]
that is Johnny Depp as Captain Jack
Sparrow in Pirates of the Caribbean this
week it was reported that Disney is
looking to reboot the franchise that's
already earned four and a half billion
dollars worldwide but the author of a
new book says the real history of
pirates is just as compelling as the
stories on the big screen Tony - copal
is here with more Tony good morning good
morning pirates were based in the
Caribbean pirates like Captain Morgan
yes
that Captain Morgan I think you may have
heard of him but they also live
throughout the American colonies in the
years before independence and their
legacy and presence there can be felt to
this day along the waterfront in Salem
Massachusetts yacht owners hoist a
familiar Black Flag while nearby
visitors linger at a museum for the men
who once sailed under the skull and
crossbones
this is the archetypal pirate this is
probably a combination of Blackbeard and
every other myth that you could put
together we've got the peg leg we've got
the hook for a hand we've got the
eyepatch
after years of researching pirates
author Eric J Dolan has come around to a
theory about why so many Americans seem
to love them perhaps there's something
exciting about the anarchy of going out
in the open ocean making your own way
plundering it we'll drinking when you
can I mean there's an exciting element
to it you think the reality
unfortunately was not quite as exciting
in his new book black flags blue waters
Dolan tries to set the record straight
so no walking the plank
no walking the plank no hooks no hooks
that I'm aware of no peg legs that
you're aware of no peg layer a few eye
patches
yes were they burying treasure no
burying treasure is another enormous
myth he decided to write the book after
pitching the idea to his kids and
immediately their eyes lit up they got
totally excited and they said dad you
have to write about pirates kids raised
of course on pirate tales like Goonies
Hook and Pirates of the Caribbean I'm
Captain Jack Sparrow Jack Sparrow may be
a myth but Dolan digs up a real history
that sparkles much the same a story of
what you might call American pirates
born bred and even celebrated here in
the 1600s so early American colonialist
were fans of pirates absolutely they
were fans of pirates because those
pirates were the fathers sons and
brothers of the people in the colonies
he says these Pirates from modern
America sailed for the Indian Ocean
where they'd attack ships traveling
between India and the Red Sea ports of
Jeddah and MOCA they'd attack these
Mughal ships and the colonists welcomed
them with open arms because they were
attacking quote-unquote heathens and
infidels Muslims halfway around the
world and bringing that treasure back to
the American colonies other pirates
commuted between the East Coast and the
Caribbean many pirates came to the
colonies with
Rich's and settled there and became
upstanding members of the community
later oh really
yeah oh yeah a lot of them yeah because
money talks back then as today pirates
were plundering mainly Spanish ships in
the Caribbean they enriched the colonies
at a time when the colonial life was
rather severe and currency starved and
most of this piracy happened without as
much bloodshed as you might think
essentially pirates were successful
because intimidation worked they would
run up the Jolly Roger of the Black Flag
and most merchant ships instead of fight
would surrender and give over their
wealth but in reality Dolan says pirates
risk their lives for what were typically
paltry sums most of these pirates didn't
have a lot of treasure to show for all
their efforts so pirates are sort of
like gamblers going into casino they
have our over expectation of success and
an under expectation of failure most of
them ended up losers even Blackbeard
he's somebody who is held out as the
archetypal pirate but his career was
only about a year a year and a half long
he didn't end up with a huge amount of
treasure and in the end his head was
severed by lieutenant Robert Maynard and
hangs from the bowsprit of his sloop Sam
Bellamy's limited lock is on display at
the pirate museum on Cape Cod they
plundered a ship called the Whydah which
had a huge amount of gold and silver on
board because it had just sold 500
slaves in Port Royal Jamaica their ship
went down off the coast of Cape Cod in
1717 killing more than a hundred men and
scattering treasure on the ocean floor
until it was found by an underwater
Explorer in 1984 certainly the greatest
treasure find that's related to pirates
in the history of the world piracy in
the Atlantic peaked in the early 1700s a
so-called Golden Age when as many as
4,000 sea robbers plied the ocean blue
when they stepped up attacks on English
ships however the Royal Navy cracked
down and this time the colonies joined
in there were 68 hangings of pirates
from Charleston to Boston in the 17
teens and from a broader perspective
there were probably more than 400
pirates that were hanged so essentially
it became a slow war of attrition
because so many people were after
pirates lost that war of course but they
rose again in our imaginations
the earliest popular account is from
1724 Charles Johnson's a general history
of the Pirates other books would add to
the lore and then of course when
Hollywood got a hold of piracy
especially when Robert Newton played
Long John Silver and Blackbeard in
Disney movies that's when we started to
get our true image of pirates today
pirates are the face of sports
franchises and still rank among the most
popular Halloween costumes
perhaps letting some people live the
pirate's life but not Eric J Dolan
camaraderie friendship adventure what
else do you need here well now to hear
you put it that way I want to become a
pirate exactly
I love the mythology as much as the next
person
but I did not find anything romantic
about it except and the legends that
were woven long after the pirates
disappeared from history's stage shiver
me timbers shiver me timbers Dolan says
he did find something worthwhile in the
way pirate ships operated as democracies
captains were picked by popular vote all
pirates were equal and there was even an
early form of disability pay for pirates
injured on the job you come across a Sam
Lord in Barbados and two of his progeny
actually one in America and one in
Canada I've actually met really rich yes
lots of money he has a cattle in
Barbados the history of pirates is based
on the ones that were caught I like to
imagine that there are some who walked
away with their money we've never heard
from them well that'd be one of them
right there I'm shocked to find out that
Blackbeard just had a good publicist
short of career than an NFL running back
thank you Tony